[Music]
sub-team reject nation it is I
Donald M Humphrey and I'm coming at you
because hey it's it's the middle of the
night but you know what trailers don't
sleep and there are some new Devil May
Cry trailers that just dropped I'm
excited to check these out
checked out the original teaser trailer
which you know it's been a long time
since we've at least seen Dante and Nero
I mean I know they remade the game but
it's been a long time since we've seen
these versions of the characters and
that got me pretty excited and then a
month ago the gameplay
you know expansion trailer dropped as
well which I checked out which looked
pretty sweet got a quick look at both
Dante and Nero's new weapons and some of
the different places you're gonna be
going in the game pretty excited to see
some more right now and quick before we
hop into this at the end of the video
gonna give a quick page from the day
shout out to my man Michael B but I just
wanted to shout out his channel at the
top of the video because he's probably
gonna check out this trailer too I would
imagine Michael knows a lot about gaming
as well as movies and other stuff so go
check out his channel Omni media and
without further ado let's hop into this
first trailer I'm gonna start with Dante
and then I'm gonna go to the Mega Buster
we're gonna go in chronological order or
at least the order of what's bigger
first here we go one two
yeah I'm man
[Music]
scoundrel Dante always been a scam
[Music]
Oh Oh Zach
not bad
[Music]
oh okay
it's all in the family man I'm gonna go
to
[Music]
yeah
whoa
don't know the power i need right here
[Music]
can't rely on gadgets alone dog like
chainsaw motorcycle
whoa that looks scary
whoa I love this world man this is my
gig
[Applause]
[Music]
you know client
he who desires but I could not read
pestilence V so it is written ha who is
this guy new character mayhaps wow the
teaser for the next Deezer who deluxe
edition huh and gets special devil
breakers interesting so pretty cool it's
kind of like a family affair I mean you
got Trish and lady in there too which I
wasn't expecting that's fun and I like
that this trailer is a bit more balanced
out - because seems like Dante keeps
showing up at the end so for this to be
the Dante trailer you know like it was
nice to start out with him and get a
good glimpse of what you're gonna be
able to do as Dante as well as some of
the Dante cutscenes it was a little bit
of that footage before jumping into Nero
and I like the idea that you're gonna
have them both you know interacting and
kind of be in side by side perhaps a
good amount or you know close by for at
least some of this game and intrigued as
ever by Nico Matt she's like a southern
evil dead version of Winry it's it's
great in fact speaking of speaking of
automail Devil breakers Tech let's hop
into this next trailer which is rated M
for blood partial nudity strong language
and violence these are just like the MPA
now it's great here we go
Mega Buster here comes the new devil
breaker
it's like Megaman
Goliath what like a side-scroller
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
for like the dog what that's an
interesting time I guess you better get
that deluxe edition if you want to fight
demons like Megaman should've worn my
proto man t-shirt for this okay not bad
I mean this is I guess this is an
effective marketing strategy they led
with you know reintroducing the
characters which is what people are
gonna be obviously psyched about because
after that hi if you watch all these
videos I make it clear I didn't play DMC
the remake and every time I touch on
that just the comments fill with ire and
vitriol for that game so you know they
lead with the reintroduction of Dante
Nero back on this timeline which I
believe is supposed to conclude the
series now or at least bring it up to
date and then you know you get a
gameplay trailer with a little bit more
of a hint at what things are gonna look
like what maybe some of your new
features and gadgets are gonna be but
not too much I mean like you got one
good look at Dante's chainsaw motorcycle
thing I don't know what that's called
yet I'm sorry and you get a couple
glimpses of Nero's devil breakers too
but I mean this gives you a much greater
look and I mean you know just makes me
want to play the game they've got a
sense of attitude back that's more in
line with at least what I remember from
some of the earlier games maybe not so
much - but I'm just really diggin the
environments and the designs you know
the creatures and stuff like that I mean
those are some of my favorite parts of
these games is just the imagination
always it's definitely taken me back to
that combat style that I'm used to and
it looks like a nice blend because I
know that the remake introduced a closer
bit more terrestrial camera and you know
this seems like it's splitting the
difference because some of those times
when you're jumping up and you're
shooting a lot or you're swiping a lot
you know the camera will punch out and
things like that and it's just cool to
see all the characters back together
again it's like you know Dante Nero
Brothe in this game you know you got
Nico riding with Nero but then to have
Trish and ladies show up and it kind of
completes the team of major you know
focal characters and then you got this
new guy v2 which you know is an
interesting looking cat I liked his new
way of goth bondage leather cape thing
tattoos kind of remind
me of like Billy from Resident Evil zero
but hey I mean I'm always excited for a
new character and it seems like you know
they're building up a neat ensemble at
least that's the vibe I got from this
trailer and it just makes me happy
especially after the reboot you know and
after it being so long it's nice to feel
like everybody's coming home and just
honor oh they're just the way they're
animating Dante Valley just looks like
that much more badass I keep on saying
I'm just gonna hashtag it now hashtag
platinum John wick and I gotta figure
out because like in this trailer
especially Nero reminded me of somebody
I just gotta figure out who and all of
her grandma is the one that made Dante's
original guns like that's pretty rad and
just to the way this trailer even starts
out you know you're back at the old
Devil May Cry agency office Dante gets a
mysterious column we're off this is
really taking me back but it's also
getting me excited for what's new I feel
like this is a nice blend of returning
to the tried and true elements of the
game while also introducing some new
stuff and just giving it a nice coat of
polish with the modern times again I
love some of these villain creatures and
stuff like that these demons look
amazing these like Reaper things these
bug like things all look amazing and
from the other trailer too I mean it
seems like they haven't lost their sense
of fun with this so you got the quippy
dialogue when they're all fighting
together and then you have his Megaman
arm which is pretty whimsical and I like
the way that they made that trailer kind
of Mega Man esque in its gameplay
mechanics you know you materialize and
then you know you have different rounds
of fighting and I wonder if maybe
that'll be an extra extra extra and it
says here in the video that the camera
angles have been altered for promotional
purposes so I don't imagine we'll get
like a specific Megaman you know level
or anything like that but it wasn't neat
to see them homage that in this trailer
yeah man I'm just wicked excited for
this now it looks super fun super
stylish and you know what else is super
fun and super stylish is our patron
objective the day that's right Michael B
aka Omni of Omni media how's it going
man are you as excited for this as I I
mean I feel like we could just talk back
and forth via shout outs now that could
be a new way of doing things but yeah if
you're still here at the end of this
video please go check out Omni media go
check out
Michael's channel that's Omni with a one
at the end because you know why make it
easy for people man no you're a renegade
you're a badass just like Dante no no
you know what actually if we made like a
we could make like a live-action Devil
May Cry you and me cuz I got the long
hair you know I can rein it in a little
bit I can be Dante I'll have to work out
for a few years but you know we can do
that and then you cuz you got a slightly
shorter hair than me you know you got
more of the boyish charm you got the
Evan Peters going on you know you can be
Nero and then we can cosplay together
and it's gonna be perfect dude I'm
telling you you gotta fly out here from
West Virginia stop helping people out
with their IT we got to do this man
I'm counting on you anyway you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell get updated every time
a review or a video is out cuz grab
button ever do that we have a patreon as
I'm sure you know by now come check us
out over there we've got a whole bunch
of really cool stuff we've got a TV show
watch lungs full length for all sorts of
things including Supernatural Riverdale
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia Gotham attack on Titan Q&A is
each week a lot of great people over
there a lot of exclusive stuff love it
if you come check us out and that's it
for now party people Cheers